in Arizona Republican officials are
trying to enforce a law on the books
from 1864.
let me say that again
1864. that's over 150 years ago
President Biden believes that Roe was
rightly decided nearly 50 years ago and
that women should be treated with
compassion they should be treated with
dignity they should be treated with
respect
and also have the Privacy to make
incredibly personal decisions
and oftentimes let's not forget
difficult decisions decisions about
their own health care
if there if there are enough votes in
Congress the first piece of legislation
the president is going to sign or he
will send to the to the hill I should
say next year in the new in the new
Congress will once again make Roe the
law of the land
and he will sign it into law around the
50th anniversary of Roe v Wade
the states could not be higher for women
across America and for the generations
of women to come
with that
something you want to kick us off good
on two topics there are reports that the
administration is considering releasing
an additional 10 to 15 million more
barrels from the Strategic petroleum
reserve and I wanted to know if you
could confirm those reports and if so
what impact do you think that release
would have on gas prices so um I don't
have anything to announce at this time
we as you know you may have heard that
we are going to make an announcement
tomorrow and so I will let the president
speak for himself and announce uh uh
make his announcement on what he said
last week he would have more to share on
what he is doing to bring gas prices or
what he will continue to do to bring gas
prices down but I do want to add a
couple of things here gas prices have
fallen by a dollar and 15 cents from
their Peak which was not too long ago
the 98 consecutive day declined this
summer was the fastest in over a decade
every month the typical two driver
family saves about 100 120 dollars at
the pump compared to where we were in
mid-june everyday Americans Americans
save about 420 million dollars at the
pump compared to mid-june now gas prices
are falling again just to give you a
little bit more of stats there the
average retail price is down by five
cents over the last week states that saw
cheaper sharper increases in recent
weeks are also seeing more rapid
declines just to give you a few States
California is down almost 30 cents this
week Wisconsin is down over 20 cents
this week Oregon is down over 20 cents
this week Michigan is down about 17 16
cents this week Ohio and Indiana are
down 13 cents this week and so those are
the few states that we're seeing the
sharp declines that are now they're not
coming down can you get any sort of
preview on the gas price I'm not going
to get as you know I would get myself in
big trouble if I got ahead of the
president so I'm not going to do that
today a lot more topic um Kevin McCarthy
did an interview with Punchbowl that was
published this morning that talked about
Ukraine Aid and talked about how
skeptical House Republicans will be of
additional Ukraine Aid if they are in
the majority and McCarthy said I think
people are going to be sitting in a
recession and they're not going to write
a blank check to Ukraine they just won't
do it so I wanted to know if the White
House is concerned about the apparent
waning bipartisan support for additional
Ukraine Aid and if that would encourage
if that would push you guys to get more
Aid in the lame duck even though you
just got 12 billion in the CR so as you
know and you kind of laid it out that
United States has provided Ukraine with
robust bipartisan support as Russia
wages its brutal war against Ukraine so
we will continue to work with Congress
and continue to monitor those
conversations on these efforts and
support Ukraine as long as it takes we
are going to keep that promise that
we're making to the brave ukrainians who
are fighting every day to fight for
their freedom and their democracy we
thank leaders across the House and
Senate Republicans and Democrats as I've
just said it was a bipartisan effort who
are working with us to hold Putin
accountable and support Port Ukraine to
defend itself from Russia's war crimes
and atrocities so this is again we're
going to closely engage we're going to
closely monitor these uh these
discussions I don't want to get ahead of
what what uh what Congress might look
like uh next year I don't want to go
into hypotheticals but again we're going
to continue to engage with Congress on
this train um why did the president
decide to give today's abortion speech
in Washington DC instead of a state like
Michigan where abortion's on the ballot
or in the state Georgia Ohio or
Pennsylvania with a Senate candidate
that's locked in a very tight right so
he's uh look for those who who traveled
with us the last those four days that we
were out west he mentioned the National
Abortion ban he mentioned what that
could mean to women across the country
if we allowed that to happen if we
allowed Senator Graham to to move
forward with such an extreme piece of
legislation and how Republicans are
taking us backwards so he has talked
about that every time he is out there
speaking directly to the American people
to talk about what is at stake for
Americans look um I I don't want to talk
about oh I can't talk about politics
from here don't want to get into into uh
into uh into that conversation as you
know I'm limited on what I can say but
look the president's going to continue
to talk about his long-standing
commitment for Reproductive Rights and
there's a clear difference as I just as
I just laid out there's a clear
difference into the approach uh the the
first bill as I just mentioned that the
president will send to Congress is going
to be to codify Roe and he will sign
that around the annivers the 15th
anniversary of Roe v Wade he is
committed to that he is committed to
making sure that we protect the rights
of women we have to understand that the
decisions that women make are incredibly
personal when it comes to their health
care it should be something that is
decided between a woman and her doctor
her family not not politicians and they
should not be stepping in on a right
that existed a constitutional right that
existed for almost 50 years and so the
president has talked about it and will
continue to do so
to send it to Congress and to califiro
is he talking about filibuster reform in
order to make that law well he talked
about that already he he's he he was
very clear a couple couple months ago
about how he would he would approve a
carve out for the filibuster when as it
relates to as it relates to this issue
so he has already made his his uh
himself very clear on that
um two different topics just to start
with the speech today twice asked voters
to remember how they felt the day the
Dove's decision came down is there a
sense that people have forgotten or that
perhaps some of the energy in the
immediate wake of that particularly
amongst some Democrats has started to
wane over the course of the last time
again I'm not going to get into the
political climate here but what I will
say is that it is very clear that
majority of Americans uh you know
support role majority of Americans
disagreed with the decision that was
made by the Supreme Court uh just a
couple of months ago and so I'll just
leave it there you see and you see that
in polling polling after polling after
polling and so the president is going to
continue to talk about the issues that
impact the American people and this one
majority of Americans have been very
clear why they stand on row and then
separately on Ukraine given the
targeting particularly of energy
infrastructure
the who warned that there's the
potential for spiraling humanitarian
crisis there's been a significant amount
of U.S economics that has gone along
with the military assistance but is the
administration considering hating
specific now to kind of triage at the
moment where this has become a very
acute and real crisis so don't have
anything specific to uh to um to preview
or announce today I can say the U.S has
delivered
8.5 billion dollars in economic
assistance since late spring and we will
continue to work with allies and
partners to support Ukraine don't have
anything else to preview
thank you does the White House have a
reaction to Reuters reporting that Iran
has promised Russia it will provide it
with surface of surface missiles as well
as foreign drones so um with that I
can't speak to those specific reports
we've already warned that Iran was
planning to sell uavs in particular to
Russia and Russia's plans to import
hundreds of these systems times Jake
Sullivan was here in at this Podium just
months ago when he made that
announcement and made that uh made that
made that very clear so we will continue
to vigorously enforce all U.S sanctions
on both the Russian and Iranian arms
trade make it harder for Iran to sell
these weapons to Russia and we will
stand with our partners throughout the
region against the Iranian threat and
will continue to Surge unprecedented
security assistance as we have done
throughout the this past year over 17
billion dollars in security assistance
to Ukraine including air defense and
working with allies to enable transfer
of air defense system of their own to
Ukraine so that is our commitment and we
will be there with the Ukrainian people
I just want to follow up on those
questions the
threat from these infrastructures or
infrastructure power stations Etc
infrastructure in Ukraine Ukraine in
demolished
must increase concern about
the training's ability to have power to
have water or heat
um
to what to what extent is that concern
president of the White House and how's
that going affect 80
. no it's a good point the uh the
attacks that we have seen from Russia
into Ukraine have been very deliberate
they have been to your point
infrastructure energy security for uh
for the people of Ukraine they are what
uh what it looks like uh we don't want
to get into the head of Putin he is
trying to make sure that the Ukrainian
people suffer right he's making it very
difficult for them and but what we
continue to see day in and day out for
the past several months is you see that
ukrainians are incredibly Brave and they
are going to continue to fight for their
freedom what I can say and what we have
said and what the president has said is
that we are going to keep our commitment
to the ukrainians and we're going to
continue to support them for as long as
it takes
hey just just one question
um President Biden clearly put the onus
on voters to elect more Democrats
um but I wonder what happens if November
8th does not go the way that he he wants
like it
does the White House have further plans
about how we will protect uh the access
to abortions or is it just the veto that
that Biden mentioned
the action very bold actions from the uh
from the beginning of this announcement
of the beginning of the decision Dobb's
decision uh on what he can do his the
authorities that he has from uh the
executive branch on how he can protect
uh the Women's Rights Acts of women to
access to Reproductive Rights women's
access to abortion
so he has been very clear about that
we've laid that out in executive again
executive actions we've heard
announcements from HHS from doj and so
we have done and will continue to do
everything that we can from here look
you know I want to be careful here I
want to be very careful of what I say
because again we cannot talk about
existing elections that are currently
happening but the president has been
very clear as on this piece which is the
way that we make Roe into law is to make
sure that we have legislation that we
codify it and so you know that is the
best way
to really protect women's rights and
that's why you continue to hear that
from this President so it's not going to
stop him from continuing to have uh to
have that conversation to continuing to
make those speeches that are going to be
really important in making that point to
the American people but again that is
what the president's going to continue
to say which is we have to codify a role
in order to protect and get to get those
protections back remember this is 50
almost 50 years of constitutional rights
that we had that was taken away by this
by the Supreme Court
just to be clear does I mean does the
White House feel like it's exhausted all
the options of everything that it can do
in the last time I mean the president
has been very clear he's he laid out
some actions right executive authorities
that he's able to take again you've
heard from the agencies that have been
involved in this process but he's always
been clear he's always said what people
need to do is to make their voices heard
what people need to do is to make sure
that we have uh we have uh you know the
votes in Congress to codify Roe he has
always made that clear in every speech
that he almost every speech he has made
about abortion rights
um uh thanks Corinne uh going back to
the speech the president mentioned his
decision on marijuana during the speech
why haven't we heard more about that
since then and do we plan on hearing
more about that soon well we later we
laid out our plan you heard directly
from the president uh on what his policy
was uh on on marijuana and um you know
you've heard that from him you heard him
mention that today I don't have any any
more
uh uh you know events to lay out about
specific specific speeches or comments
about marijuana but you heard directly
from the president about what his policy
is and uh and he kept his promise his
commitment that he made during the
campaign I'm trying to get specific how
many more votes does the president think
he needs in the Senate to codify Rose 51
52 I'm not going to get ahead of uh of
this election or talk about this
election so I'm gonna this was a
political speech and not going to weigh
into any specific numbers you did say if
there are enough votes in Congress the
president would send that's his first
bill in the 118th Congress and build a
codify road you can't say how many is
enough no I'm camp if the country sends
to Congress
a House and Senate that are not
interested in codifying Roe or busting
filibuster to do so what is the
president's top legislative priority in
that case
if it's say that one more time let's say
the House and Senate do not
fall into Republic Democrat hands let's
let's say that Republicans take the
house what will be the first bill the
president sends to Congress that's a lot
of hypotheticals let's let's first let's
first get let me but I know we're all
talking about hypotheticals but I've
also said I'm going to be very careful
about what I say from here so I've also
LED with that as well uh but that is
like that is a different type of
hypothetical that I'm just not going to
uh to to preview from here at this time
so is it fair to say that that abortion
rights currently is the president's top
legislative priority when it comes what
he what the president has said is he's
showing his commitment how important uh
Roe is to him how important Reproductive
Rights is because majority of Americans
believe that this right needs to stand
uh and that they they believe that the
50 years nearly 50 years of rights that
they had constitutional rights that they
had and that was taken away you know is
not is is is going backwards not forward
and so he is going to continue to talk
about issues that are packed impacting
the American people and this is one of
them by saying by laying out what he is
going to do uh next year with the 50
50th Anniversary uh laying out that he's
going to his first piece of legislation
will be on codifying Roe is just showing
his commitment to where majority of
Americans are
on uh Mexico the president of Mexico has
said that President Biden is going to be
traveling there in December would you be
able to say if if that's accurate if
he's right on that so we're still
working uh working through plans for the
next North Americans leaders Summit and
have no travel announcement to make at
this time
and then he also said that President
Biden arranged a phone call with him
today is that right so the president is
going to speak with the president of
Mexico uh today on a range of issues
from U.S Mexico priorities and we'll
have a readout as soon as that
conversation is coming but one more on
the spr release some White House
officials have been talking for the last
few days about the fact that it's a
possibility
um can you explain why with gas prices
you mentioned earlier the gas prices are
going down again
why would the U.S need another spr
release from that 180 million barrels
that you already announced why would you
be that now if prices are already
dropping so again I'm not going to get
ahead of the the president as you know
there's going to be an announcement
tomorrow on the president's uh policy
next move uh his next move forward on
what he's going to do to help the
American people give them continue to
give them a little bit of a breathing
room but President Biden has said for
months how he is committed to doing
everything that he can in his power to
address Putin's price hike he has said
this on almost every speech you've heard
him talk about when it comes to gas
prices and what what the American people
are seeing and feeling at the pump and
he's been delivering on that so uh you
know as you know gas prices have indeed
come down I just listed some of the
states where we had seen a an increase
and now we're seeing a decline this past
week they came down at the fastest Pace
in over a decade this summer and have
continued you to fall in recent days and
but at the same time Putin's War
continues his war on Ukraine his
unprovoked War Buddha war and Ukraine
continues and so it puts pressure on our
Global energy supplies because of this
war and so he's going to continue to
take action the president President
Biden is going to continue to take
action to make sure that he lowers costs
do you have any response to those who
would say who are criticizing the White
House saying that this seems like a ploy
ahead of the midterms
look the president I would say to this
to folks
um should the president not do
everything that he can to lower prices
should he not continue to keep his prime
promise to give American people a little
bit of breathing room you know that's
the promise that he's made should he not
do that and so that's what you're seeing
right now uh this is something that he
has done throughout the summer this is
something that he has done to address
Putin's price hike and this is something
that he's done to meet the global
challenges that are in front of us
uh it's been eight months since Brittany
Greiner became a detainee of the
Russians she turned 32 years old today a
statement that was released through her
representative said thank you to
everyone for fighting so hard to get me
home all the support and love are
definitely helping me my first question
as it relates to Brittany Greiner is has
the U.S had any Consular access to
Brittany Greiner since the beginning of
August as of last week they had not had
they in the course of the last week so I
want to be very clear here because this
is important this is important to the
president this is important to this
Administration getting Brittany home
getting Paul Whalen home is a priority
for this Administration they are
wrongfully detained and they should be
home today and so the president his
National Security Council the state
department is going to do everything
that we can to get them home I don't
have anything else to preview for you at
this time or to update you but it is a
it is a um it is continues continues to
be a priority for this Administration
frustration about that so you can't say
if in the last week There's been any
access to her right so we're going to
continue to work through our channels
home getting Paul home in terms of
access we can't we presently can't say I
guess how do we how do we how do we tell
the American people do we know that she
is well do we know that her condition is
well right now when's the last time we
got some indication of her circumstance
no it's a very good question don't have
any don't have any update on you uh for
you on that piece what I can say it is a
priority you've heard this President you
heard from secretary blinken you've
heard from the National Security advisor
and we are going to continue to talk
through on our channels until this moves
from a priority to a reality we've had
success as you know Peter with bringing
Americans home from Russia from
Afghanistan from Venezuela from Burma
from Haiti uh West Africa and more so we
have had success in doing this we're
going to keep we're going to be
steadfast on on making sure that
Brittany and Paul come home one quick
follow-up I know we're gonna hear from
the president more details it relates to
the questions my colleagues have asked
about oil specifically but can you today
rule out an export and that would send
oil overseas I
I the president addressed that
specifically I'm not going to
[Music]
Choose Or Not address I'm not going to
get ahead of him we'll let him make the
announcement tomorrow so be clear if
you're not going to get ahead of him
that means that's an issue about which
he'll be speaking so you don't want to
get out of it that is that is not what I
said
if I'm not asking about what he's going
to say that specific question and I'm
answering that specific question which
is I'm not going to get ahead of the
president he's going to make his
announcement tomorrow okay thanks thanks
Kareem following up on something Steve
was asking what is President Biden's top
domestic priority now is it inflation or
is it abortion
the president's going to continue to
talk about issues that matter to the
American people and abortion is one of
them majority of the American people
disagree with the decision that that the
Supreme Court made the Dobbs decision
that is a majority of the people uh
disagreed with that when it comes to the
economy the president has made it very
very clear when it comes to inflation it
is his number one economic priority and
he is doing everything that he cans to
make sure that we lower prices
it's his number one economic priority
we've heard the president say inflation
is his top domestic priority but now
he's saying
come next year his first bill would be
abortion related so is his number one
domestic priority abortion or is it
inflation I forget what the president
has done the last 19 months he has made
the economy his top priority he he's
passed the American Rescue plan by by
the way as you heard me say all the time
no Republicans voted for that in
Congress and it was a plan that helped
us get back on our feet with the economy
that helped us gain or create 10 million
jobs that we had lost it also put money
in people's pockets it also make sure
that businesses were were able to open
up schools were able to open up people
were able to go back into their homes
save their homes and so that was the
American Rescue plan that's the
bipartisan infrastructure legislation
which was again to invest in ports
invest in the infrastructure that was
dwindling and so that is something that
he did the inflation reduction act that
is lowering cost for the American people
he is working on the economy every day I
just announced yesterday or we just
announced yesterday hearing aids 30
million people are going to benefit from
hearing aids saving thousands of dollars
a year so that's working on the economy
every day so he said he's been working
on the economy every day for 19 months
now Bloomberg economists are forecasting
a 100 percent chance of a recession so
how is it that we can be barreling
towards a recession uh and the economy
is as the President says strong as hell
so here's the thing about the economy
and I've said this many times you've
heard this from secretary yelling you've
heard this from Brian deese who runs our
Economic Council is that what we are
seeing right now is the job market is
strong the labor force is strong and
that is not what we see usually before
uh before a recession and so the and a
lot of that is because of the work that
this president has done we were seeing
an economy that is resilient we are
seeing an economy that is going through
to into a transition with more stable
growth more steady growth and that is
because of the work that this president
has done that is because of the economic
policy that he has put forward and let
me remind you the economic policy that
he's put forward is about building the
economy from the bottom to to from the
bottom to the top and the middle out and
that is so important because it means
that we leave no one behind it means
that there's equity in everything that
he puts forward and so again you're
going to hear from the president about
gas prices that's again trying to make
sure that we continue to keep prices low
for the American people that's what just
if President Biden keeps going to the
petroleum reserves when there are energy
problems is he giving up on his campaign
pledge to end fossil fuel so I want to
be very clear on that piece
um you know there is no shortage of
opportunity or incentive for oil
companies to ramp up production we've
made that clear oil companies are
ranking in record profits as we have
seen they have showed it themselves
we've seen it ourselves while more than
9 000 approved drilling permits remain
untapped by the oil industry at the same
time U.S oil production is up and on
track to reach a record high this year
again a record high in fact the United
States has produced more oil in
President Biden's first year than under
the Trump administration's first year
okay we're going to move on
Haiti the U.S is trying to work on a
resolution that would get the security
Council to sort of support something
that they call the non-un security
Mission led by a partner country can you
tell us what that would look like and
talking about the U.S specifically does
that possibly include actual U.S troops
or would that be logistical support
financial support so um as as you heard
from the Ambassador Ambassador Thomas
Greenfield yesterday she laid out in her
remarks at the U.N security Council the
United States and Mexico are working on
a draft U.N security Council resolution
that would authorize a non to your point
a non-un International Security
assistance mission to help improve the
security situation in Haiti as she noted
the resolution would outline a mission
led by a U.S partner country with deep
experience and it would be limited and
carefully scoped that is what the what
that is what we laid out yesterday
conversations are ongoing with partners
with necessary experience that have
expressed the interest of leading that
effort in contributing to a non-un
mission and playing leading or Central
roles in the effort as well as I just
stated the United States is considering
the most effective ways to directly
support enable and resource such an
effort again they are conversations are
ongoing on how to move this process
forward there's still a possibility or
consideration for possible U.S troops or
is that off the table again it is the
ongoing conversations on how to move
forward I'm not going to lay those out
right now
um I have two questions one is domestic
and one is foreign
School showed yesterday that more than a
third of independent voters and a
smaller but small contingent of
Democrats said that they are open to
supporting candidates who reject the
legitimacy of the 2020 election so while
you highlight in the emotional issues
obviously the voters are focusing on
recession inflation and economy how
worried is the White House considering
uh this poll that was published by the
New York Times can you say can you say
it again the beginning of uh sure the
poll showed that more than a third of
independent voters and a small
contingent of Democrats said they are
open
award or to support candidates who
reject the legitimacy of 2020 election
you know we've spoken about that many
times about
about those about those who voted and I
want to be careful well it's the past
election of 2020 and how they uh and the
legitimacy of of 2020. look
um when the president came into office
he understood uh the importance of
um his election the importance of the
moment that he was in the importance of
bringing people together and so you know
we are aware of that we are aware of how
people may feel about the last election
but the president's going to stay
steadfast on the American people he's
going to he has always said he's he is a
president for people who voted for him
or in people who didn't vote for him
he's a president for people who live in
red States and blue States it doesn't
matter to him but also
um you know that's why you hear him talk
about the importance of democracy the
important the importance of making sure
that we protect and fight for our
democracy you heard him give a very
powerful thoughtful speech not too long
ago in Pennsylvania about this very
issue and so he's going to certainly
you'll continue to hear from him how
important it is to make sure that we
live up to our uh to our um you know to
who we are as a country and also in
foreign policy uh president zielinski
thanks the Saudis for given 400 million
dollar in humanitarian Aid uh do you
welcome this and uh considering your
grievances against opiate plus that
whatever they did was indirectly helping
the Russians
so look the decisions that uh OPEC plus
made
um just last week uh is uh it was we
believe uh cited with the Russians and
was against the interests of the
American people in the families around
the world we believe that decision is
going to hurt and harm low uh you know
low lower income economies and uh and uh
it is a it was a a misguided and it was
a mistake and a short-sighted decision
and so look we've talked about what the
president's going to do next he's going
to reevaluate his relationship with uh
with Saudi Arabia this is something that
he has talked about since the beginning
of this Administration he wants to do it
in a bipartisan way which is the way it
has been done for the last eight decades
where we talk about a relationship with
Saudi Arabia so he is going to do this
in a methodical way in a strategic way
and he is going to certainly get input
from members of both parties but it
doesn't take away I know it you just
laid out the assistant but it doesn't
take away what Opex plus did that
decision was a mistake and so again
we're going to reevaluate that
relationship and we'll have more to
share yeah
go ahead thanks
very much for following up on that are
any bite Administration officials
planning to go to the Future investment
initiative conference in Riyadh Saudi
Arabia later this month we don't have
anything to preview or announce at this
time on any travel do you think it's
appropriate for U.S businesses to
continue their engagement or investment
in the Kingdom in light of uh what
happened recently so as they do in every
part of the world American companies
will make their own decisions about
their presence and where to invest
taking into account a range of factors
including legal constraints the business
environment and reputational concerns
that can arise from public policy
choices made by host countries I think I
want to follow up on the Saudi Arabia
question and then ask one about student
loans one of the arguments Saudi Arabia
is making to justify their decision to
increase moral production is that the
price of oil is about the same as what
it was before Russia invaded Ukraine
what's wrong with that argument
look we've made it we've made it very
clear uh that in the time of uh what's
going on what we're seeing with the
global markets uh the decision that they
made the OPEC OPEC plus decision uh was
a mistake it was short-sighted uh we've
been very clear about that uh and uh you
know again the way that we see it it was
uh they sided with with Russia on this
and it's going to hurt American the
American people it's going to hurt
families across across the country and
we will have more to share on how our
relationship is going to look like
moving forward
[Music]
yesterday secretary Cardone has said the
administration is working on ways to
forgive and privately held student loans
can you say how confident you are that
that will happen and whether borrowers
can expect an announcement on that
before they have to return
um I'm going to leave that to the
Department of Education like you said
secretary Cardona is working on that uh
so we don't have anything to share at
this time uh clearly it is a priority
and something that is an important uh
important for this Administration to
make sure that private borrowers are
also have an opportunity here
we just want to see parts of the
briefing room you know come to the back
maybe
on Brittany Greiner has the
administration have any recent
Communications with Russia a thousand uh
these cases in an attempt to win uh
Brittany Bryant
look look as we've as we've said before
we try to keep these negotiations
um uh private and just don't have
anything to share on any recent
conversations but this is a priority and
then just went on a pipeline police in
Denmark said that their preliminary
investigation into the leaks and
Military wanted to uh they said it was
caused by a power Thing by a powerful
explosion that's in line with what
Sweden has said earlier does the
administration have any
reaction to these new findings and does
the president believe that Russia was
behind this election well the president
has been very clear that it was clearly
a sabotage when it comes to the pipeline
we've also said we know this
investigation is going to take some time
and it's going to be a long process
before we get to the end of it so don't
want to get ahead of ahead of the
investigation
I wanted to follow up on some of the
questions from yesterday about the
midterms and I understand you have the
hash act to consider but um what I was
curious is even though we're seeing the
president out there he's been doing
these smaller events with smaller
audiences he's been doing closed door
fundraisers with no photographers why
aren't we seeing big campaign rallies or
is anything on the schedule with the
election less than three weeks away look
I can't answer that question from here
uh uh it is a a election election that's
currently happening at this time so I am
very limited to what I can say from the
podium from the white house uh what I
can say is that the president has been
on the road he will continue to be on
the road
um
uh
just can't say more than that you have
seen him he was in Portland Oregon uh
doing events he was in California doing
events and he was in Colorado doing
events
um I will say that they were all pretty
well attended but I'll leave it there
can I also just follow up he has been
doing less travel than for example what
we saw President Obama do in the the
first in October of 2010 can you give
anything about the schedule anything
that may be coming up any stops he may
be doing
well we announced that he's as you know
he's going to go to Pennsylvania on
Thursday he's going to go to Florida on
November 1st uh there will be more
travel to come certainly not going to
get ahead of of any announcements uh
from here uh but again the president as
you know and we have said this many
times before he enjoys getting out there
he enjoys talking to the American people
this is something that he wants to
continue to do and we have something to
talk about right we have some uh
successes some wins to talk about and I
just laid them out the inflation
reduction act and a lower cost for uh
for health care costs for American
people is going to lower cost for our
seniors as we talk about Medicare it's
going to lower energy costs these are
real wins that we have delivered for the
American people that Congressional
Democrats have delivered for the
American people where Republicans their
plan their plan is to take that away
they want they want to take away
lowering costs on Health Care they want
to take away a lowering cost on energy
and so what the president's going to
continue to do is figure out how he's
going to deliver for what matters the
most for the American people
thank you
the president promised to send a bill to
Congress to codify row earlier today
I've got two basic questions about that
number one would that bill simply codify
row or would it go farther and overturn
individual State abortion restrictions
and then number two are there any
abortion restrictions at all that the
president would support
what the president is going to do and
wants to do and believes in doing is a
codifying roe he believes uh that is uh
what it was the the law of the land the
constitutional right for almost 50 years
uh and it's he believes in its specific
Provisions was rightly decided he has
said this regularly including right
after Dobbs and that has not changed
right but that's that didn't answer
either question there's first of all
there are individual State restrictions
on abortion in the on the books
currently around the country some of
those existed before the Dobbs case
before the overturn Pro with the
president with this bill codify row does
he want that bill to go farther and I
just I just answered that question and
who believes he I just answered that
question he believes in Roe and how and
how it stood before the dops decision
okay and then on the individual restrict
or are there any restrictions whatsoever
that the president would support when it
comes to abortion people again he
believes in the provisions that Roe had
um and that's where he stands I would
suggest you reading it so you get a
sense of what the president uh stands
and what he wants to see all right
shifting to a different topic then
um why is it that the president was
talking about nuclear Armageddon behind
closed doors to political donors two
weeks ago
rather than speaking directly with the
American people about that topic well
they always press your colleagues there
were a few of your colleagues that were
in the room
well given the severity and the
significance of that threat isn't that
something that the President should
perhaps what we've talked about we
should I mean but there was there was
again there was press in the room it's
not like he was saying he was not saying
it in secret he knew that the Press was
in the room at the time when he was
making the comments look the president
we've talked about this this is like two
weeks ago conversation we we we've
talked about this in in detail about how
seriously we take uh Putin's saber
rattling uh Putin's comments about
nuclear using nuclear weapons that is
something that we take seriously do we
see anything at this time that uh that
causes us to move our our strategic
positioning no not at this time but it
matters that that's that rhetoric is
being used and so the president has
spoken to this uh I have spoken to this
the National Security advisor has spoken
to this uh again it was not in secret
the reason why you know that it happened
is because there were reporters there go
ahead thank you I'll follow up on the
first of uh the questions just now is
there any uh chance that OMD and they
put out the text of whatever this
legislative proposal is before say a
democratic majority on January third of
next year that people can see exactly
what the legislative language is that
that is being proposed here because the
the bill that they voted on on Capitol
Hill a couple of times the women's
Women's Health protection act
was broader than than what I believe
you're talking about now well as the
president said that he would send this
piece of legislation right to Congress
and he believes Roe and its specific
Provisions should stand that's what this
piece of legislation that he would write
that he would send to Congress would
look like and he's been very very clear
about this he made that statement when
he when the Dobb's decision was decided
in in June he is very very clear that
what wrote The Rose decision was rightly
the when Roe was first put into place
that was the in its in its form was
rightly decided and that's what he wants
to see and that's what you're going to
see he pushed forward in the next uh
Congress I'll follow up on the student
loan question that was last asked a
little earlier too I
the President yesterday for those of us
who were in The Southport Auditorium
mentioned the concerns about the legal
challenges is there a message to the
people the tens of millions of Americans
who are signing up for this forgiveness
right now who may be eager to see it
actually come into their their accounts
who may face the possibility that at
least for a while there's a federal
judge somewhere who stops it look the
president is uh is committed to this
right this is a policy that he put
forward because he wanted to give a
little bit of breathing room to the
American people to the middle class this
is also a campaign promise that he
wanted to keep because it he knew how
important it was to so many people we're
talking about almost 40 million people
who are going to get borrowers who are
going to get the uh who are going to be
able to get the effects of this policy
23 million people are going to see their
debt their college debt already wiped
away that matters that matters we're
talking about 90 percent of the folks
who are going to be the borrowers who
are going to be getting this relief are
making under seventy five thousand
dollars so he's committed to this and
he's going to make sure do everything
that we can to make this an easy process
and we've seen that already from the
website and the thing to remember I
think the question to ask or the thing
to actually really think about here is
what Republicans are trying to do when
you look at these lawsuits across the
country they're coming from Republicans
and Republicans want to take away this
essential need that folks again ninety
percent of these folks are making 70
less than seventy five thousand dollars
who need a little bit more of a
breathing room
opportunity to get a family started who
need an opportunity to just live their
lives in a little a little bit easier
way and so that's the question to be
asking why are Republicans doing this
thank you